this is Tara Langston who posted a video
from intensive care to warn others to
take the virus seriously there is a
warning that some viewers may find the
clip distressing anyone anyone is
thinking taking any chances just take a
look at me I'm in the intensive care
unit I can't breathe without this
they've had to sew that into my artery
please none of you take any chances I
mean it because if it gets really bad
then you're gonna end up here Tara's
back home joins us from Ruislip in
Northwest London Tara welcome thanks for
joining us how will you know I call you
thank you for having me on I feel so
much better today and every time I hear
that clip and see that clip it that clip
was actually taken whilst I was in ICU
and it just sort of transports me right
back to that moment in time and you know
I took that that videos as I've sent it
till what's that group to my work
friends and then it went viral and you
know it's um it brings it all back sort
of what it was like being in ICU for
those three days it was pretty scary so
you were in with it for three days was
that towards the moment where you were
discharged because although you were
obviously struggling for breath and
you're in distress in that video you
compos mentis I mean you're clearly able
to think and you're aware of what's
going on around you absolutely and my
body had been fighting this virus for
quite some time at home and I went into
the hospital they swapped me they
admitted me and it was I think three
days later that they realized that my
swap had come back positive preview so
that I was in an eye
related room and as Simon was saying
before the gentleman that was speaking I
was on four liters of oxygen and you
know four liters of oxygen is four
liters of oxygen but actually needing
any oxygen at all is very distressing
and traumatic when you can't physically
use the bathroom because you know you
can't breathe it's very distressing and
what happened for me was I then went up
I needed five liters of oxygen
I needed six liters of oxygen and with
that also I had pneumonia on both my
lungs so to know that the Prime Minister
doesn't have pneumonia that is really
positive and really good news and I
think it's after four liters of oxygen
that they then admit you to ICU and I
just want to use this moment to touch on
the nurses and doctors even the cleaners
everyone is fighting this fight the
doctors and nurses at Hillingdon
Hospital they really took good care of
me and they are the most incredible
people that you could ever hope to me
and as you're lying there you know don't
you they're doing everything they can
with the resources that they've got
their disposal to keep you alive but it
must have cry it must have crossed your
mind Tara that this might be it for you
you might be about to die yeah
I was sobbing I when you cry and you
panic your breathing gets even worse and
I just thought that I wasn't gonna see
my girls grow up and the thought of
being sedated and intubated was really
scary I actually had patients on either
side to me who were intubated and I saw
how they were being treated every time a
nurse or a doctor had to you know do
something for them they were talking to
them as if they were conscious they were
taking a diary a journal for them
because when you're intubated you lose
days you lose time and it really helped
to put my emotions at ease because I
thought right well if it gets that bad
and I need
to be sedated I know that I'm in safe
hands and I'm gonna be in good care but
it is scary and you do think the worst
and that's obviously the worst thing for
you at the time because then your
breathing just exhaust breaks and gets
worse and you just need to calm down in
a sense your story ty was encouraging I
mean you know you had pneumonia but you
weren't intubated we're told from
Downing Street that Boris Johnson
doesn't have pneumonia
he appears perhaps he's just going a bit
if I can put it this way gentle help in
terms of his breathing and if that's so
then you know if when if we're lucky
he'll make a full recovery and fairly
quickly I had to have the CPAP which is
this very is quite suffocating actually
it's not pleasant it's a big mass that
you have and it really opens up your
lungs to get oxygen in there and from
having that I turned a corner which I'm
so grateful for but you know everyone's
different and I know for me when I left
the ICU I then had to spend some time on
another ward in an isolated room and you
know what I just wanted to sleep my body
was so tired so exhausted your body is
working as hard as it can to fight the
virus and I just wanted to sleep and you
know Boris Johnson has has been
fantastic so far and my heart goes out
to his family and his partner because
she is expecting I have friends and
family who are expecting as well at the
moment and they're trying to navigate
their way through this because it's just
so frightening so you know I think the
fact that he doesn't have pneumonia is a
really positive sign but he does need to
get some rest
up you know after this as well if he can
I don't know he's a busy guy it's
wonderful you back with your family and
we really appreciate you sharing your
story and it does the trick it does tell
people what potentially might happen if
they don't take all the due precautions
really good to talk to you thanks a lot
he's I'm not